die Stärke einer Landeswährung hängt von
der Stärke der Landwirtschaft ab Amerika
hat mit Abstand die stärkste Wirtschaft
der
Welt folglich habe ich den
Finanzminister angewiesen die nötigen
Schritte zu ergreifen um den Dollar vor
Spekulanten zu
schützen Minister con wurde angewiesen
vorübergehend die eintauschbarkeit des
Dollars in Gold oder andere reserewerte
aufzuheben sern die Mengen und
Bedingungen nicht der finanziellen
und den Interessen der Vereinigten
Staaten dienlich
sind der 15 August 1971 wird noch für
viele Generationen ein entscheidendes
Ereignis der Wirtschaftsgeschichte sein
selbst in hunderten von Jahren wird man
sich noch daran
erinnern
[Musik]
das auch heute geht die Sonne auf wie
schon millionenfach
zuvorleren ins Büro um ihr Tagwerk zu
verrichten Landwirte kümmern sich um die
Ernte und Bauarbeiter errichten neue
Infrastruktur es ist ein Tag wie jeder
andere oder nicht 2008 erlebte die Welt
eines der größten wirtschaftsbeben aller
Zeiten weltweit brachen die Märkte ein
und Finanzinstitutionen die einst als
unangreifbar galten drohten in sich
zusammenzufallen Regierungen reagierten
schnell und beschlossen Rettungs und
Konjunkturpakete um die Weltwirtschaft
über Wasser zu halten mit Erfolg die
globale Wirtschaft erholte sich viel
schneller als die meisten erwarteten und
alles war wieder wie
zuvor und doch stimmt etwas nicht
ganz die Unruhe in der Bevölkerung nimmt
zu in der Finanzwelt wenn nicht gar in
allen Bereichen des modernen Lebens tun
sich Risse auf
[Musik]
viele haben
Angst wenn man die Menschen auf der
Straße fragt wissen sie zwar nicht was
genau los ist aber sie spüren dass etwas
nicht
stimmt die Regierung macht Verluste in
Billionenhöhe warum wächst die
Wirtschaft nicht wieder die Regierung
gibt fast 3,7 Billionen Dollar aus warum
habe ich keine Arbeit warum liegt die
Arbeitslosigkeit bei 9% wenn ich sogar
höher
viele in der heutigen Welt sind
verunsichert und besorgt dass etwas
Schreckliches bevorstehen könnte es
heißt die Weltfinanzkrise von vor ein
paar Jahren sei überwunden was aber wenn
die Krise nicht einfach nur die Ursache
unserer Angst war sondern Symptom eines
viel tiefer greifenden
[Musik]
problems ierten aus 44 Ländern der
Alliierten zur Eröffnung der UN
finanzkonferenz
ein die Geschichte beginnt
1944 am Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs
trafen sich die Alliierten in
bretonwoods New Hampshire um ein neues
Finanzsystem zu etablieren und die Welt
in der Nachkriegszeit zu stabilisieren
da man ein goldenes Zeitalter für die
USA erwartete wurde der US-Dollar zur
Leitwährung
ernannt Breton woodZ System wurde nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg bei der Konferenz
in Bretton woodZ
erschaffen anstatt Gold als Tauschmedium
zwischen Ländern zu verwenden wie es
beim vorigen Goldstandard der Fall war
entschied man sich den Dollar zu
verwenden denn der war damals so gut wie
Gold in diesem neuen System wurde für
jede Landeswährung ein fester
Wechselkurs zum Dollar bestimmt der
Dollar war mit einem festen Preis von
35$ pro Unze an Gold gebunden
somit konnten alle Länder der Welt ihre
Währung in Dollar und diese dann in Gold
umwandeln dadurch waren letztlich in
diesem System alle Währungen durch Gold
gedeckt um das physische Gold nicht über
den Globus verschicken zu müssen wurde
das Gold in das andere Länder ihre
Währungen eintauschten zumeist sicher in
den USA
verwahrt unter dem Bron wystem konnten
andere Länder und Zentralbank
ih W undllar in Gold
umtauschen dann fingen die
Haushaltsdefizite an das great Society
Programm von Lindon Johnson der Krieg in
Vietnam plötzlich waren wir Minus und
die anderen Länder gaben ihre Dollar ab
und wollten
Gold zuerst Frankreich dann immer
mehr in Anbetracht der wachsenden
Ausgaben befürchteten andere Länder die
USA könten mehr Geld ausgeben erven
abdecken sie tauschten ihre Dollar in
Gold um und verlangten physische
goldlieferungen da sie vermuteten es
würden mehr Dollar gedruckt als Gold
vorhanden war um die Abwanderung des
Goldes aus den US Tresoren zu
unterbinden ließ Präsident nien den
Umtausch in Gold
aussetzen folglich habe ich den
Finanzminister angewiesen die ntig
Schritte zu
ergreen Spekulanten zu
schützen Minister con wurde angewiesen
vorübergehend die eintauschbarkeit des
Dollars in Gold oder andere
reserveewerte
aufzuheben alle Probleme unseres
aktuellen Finanzsystems sind direkte
Folgen der Entscheidung vom 15 August
1971 die feste Verbindung zum Gold
aufzugeben Gold Zwang Regierungen zur
Disziplin und zur Mäßigung ihrer
Ausgaben hatte man im alten System ein
Defizit wurde so lange Gold ausgeführt
bis das Gleichgewicht wiederhergestellt
war ohne die Abdeckung durch Gold sind
Staaten nun dauerhaft im Defizit die USA
z.B hatten seit 1971 keinen
Haushaltsüberschuss mehr seit wir vom
Goldstandard weg sind hatten wir
durchgehend konjunkturdefizite in guten
wie in schlechten
Zeiten Nixon hob 1971 den Goldstandard
auf angeblich nur vorübergehend aber wir
warten noch immer auf die
Wiedereinführung wir machten in den
60ern massive
Verluste aufgrund der Gansen
bterwirtschaft bei der die Regierung zum
einen Krieg in Vietnam führte und zum
anderen bemannte Mondmissionen und das
Raumfahrtprogramm finanzierte mussten
wir mehr Geld drucken als unsere
Goldreserven
zuließen viele unserer ausländischen
Kreditgeber sahen das und verlangten
Gold anstatt der Bank
weil sie spürten dass Washington nicht
genug Gold haben würde um das
wertversprechen des Dollars
einzuhalten indem er die Verbindung zum
Gold kappte chuf Präsident Nixon ein
System in dem alle Währungen durch
nichts gedeckt waren man spricht hierbei
von
fiatwährungen fiatwährungen sind durch
nichts außer Versprechen von Regierungen
gedeckt kommt aus dem Lateinischen es
ist also Geld das durch Zwang im Umlauf
ist wenn die Menschen der Währung
Vertrauen und die Regierung genug Macht
hat bleibt die Währung eine Weile lang
im Umlauf bis die Menschen das Vertrauen
wieder
verlieren kein Land der Welt verwendet
aktuell tatsächliches Geld wir alle
nutzen Währungen irgendwann werden wir
alle den Unterschied
erkennen Geld ist ein austauschmedium es
war dabei immer etwas das von sich aus
Wert hatte bis zur Moderne Politiker
sagen wir brauchen nichts Wertvolles
mehr wir brauchen nur politische
Entscheidungen wir sagen einfach dieses
Stück Papier wäre Geld jetzt hat Geld
eine neue Eigenschaft aber grundsätzlich
gilt das gleiche Konzept dass niemand
anzuzweifeln wagt nämlich dass
Regierungen das Recht haben etwas an
sich wertloses zu Geld zu erklären und
das man das zu akzeptieren habe das ist
ein Problem und es zerstört auch heute
noch die
Weltwirtschaft
da Währungen nicht mehr durch echte
Werte gedeckt sind bemisst sich ihr Wert
nur noch im Verhältnis
zueinander Länder mit schwachen
Währungen können Produkte günstig
herstellen also entwerten sie ihre
Währungen gezielt um als Handelspartner
attraktiver zu
werden jede Papierwährung vergleicht
sich mit dem
Dollar sinkt der Dollar reagieren die
Zentralbanken anderer Länder und
schreiten auf dem Währungsmarkt ein
damit die Auswirkungen ihre Wirtschaft
nicht
beeinträchtigen was ist ein Ponzi System
ein Ponzi System ist ein betrügerisches
investmentangebot das Investoren große
Gewinne bei keinem oder geringem Risiko
verspricht klingt zu gut um wahr zu sein
stimmt bei seriösen investmentmodellen
wird das Geld zur Wertschöpfung in
risikoarme anlageewerte die Aktien oder
Immobilienportfolios investiert mit der
Zeit generiert dies genug Einkommen um
die Investition zuzüglich eines profits
zurückzuzahlen ein Ponzi System
verspricht jedoch gewaltige Gewinne in
kürzester Zeit wie funktioniert das
anstatt das Geld sinnvoll zu investieren
werden bei einem Ponzi System einfach
mehr Investoren gewonnen um die vorigen
Investoren
auszuzahlen da den neuen Investoren auch
große Gewinne versprochen wurden muss
anschließend eine noch größere Gruppe
gefunden werden um sie zu bezahlen
während die Initiatoren einen Teil des
Geldes jeder Gruppe für sich
behalten da das ponzystem selbst keinen
Wert generiert müssen kontinuierlich
immer größere Investorengruppen
hinzugezogen werden damit es weiter
funktioniert irgendwann findet man keine
neuen Investoren mehr oder eine große
Anzahl der bisherigen Investoren will
sich zeitgleich auszahlen lassen wodurch
das System
zusammenbricht zu dem Zeitpunkt haben
die Initiatoren gewaltige Beträge für
sich beiseite geschafft und die
Investoren haben keine Gewinne sondern
Pech
gehabt ohne feste Verbindung zum Gold
konnte die us-staatskasse beliebig viel
Geld leihen und
ausgeben braucht die US-Regierung Geld
leih sie es sich von der
usnenbank die Notenbank druckt die für
das darlh erforderlichen Banknoten und
bekommt von der Staatskasse einen
Schuldschein
die Schuldscheine nennt man
Staatsanleihen mit dem Geld dieser
Darlehen oder Anleihen bezahlt die
US-Regierung ihre Rechnungen und
Verpflichtungen zeitgleich versteigern
die usstaatskasse und die Notenbank
diese Anleihen gemeinsam bei Auktionen
wo ausländische Zentralbanken
Rentenfonds und auch Einzelpersonen
diese US-Staatsanleihen kaufen warum
auch nicht der US-Regierung Geld zu
leihen war seit jeer eine sichere
wenn die darl jedoch für Rechnungen und
die Auszahlung früher Anleihen genutzt
werden woher bekommt die Regierung das
Geld um die aktuellen Anleihen mit
Zinsen zurückzuzahlen ist die
Investition in Anleihen der US-Regierung
letztlich Teil eines gewaltigen
ponziystems das System der usnenbank ist
ein ponystem ganz ohne
Zweifel sie geben vor der Regierung Geld
zu leihen und die Regierung sag Geld mit
Zinsen
zurückzuzahlen das Geld wird tatsächlich
erst für genau diesen Zweck erschaffen
und der Regierung gegeben vorher
existierte es gar nicht Zentralbanken
erschaffen es aus dem Nichts mit ein
paar computerclicks erschaffen Sie eine
Billionen Dollar die die Staatskasse der
Regierung nun ausgeben kann so einfach
entsteht das Geld die US-Regierung ist
nun aber verpflichtet das Geld mit
Zinsen zurückzuzahlen die Zinsen darf
man nicht vergessen
wenn sie es zurückzahlen müssen können
sie das nicht schon gar nicht mit
Zinsen also leihen Sie sich einfach noch
mehr Geld um die ursprünglichen Kredite
mit Zinsen zu
bezahlen der Kongress will dann sowieso
mehr Geld und der schuldenwerk wächst
und wächst und
wächst im aktuellen Währungssystem
entsteht unser Geld dadurch dass wir es
uns leihen und versprechen es mit Zinsen
zurückzubezahlen wenn der erste und
einzige Dollar der Welt dadurch entsteht
dass man sich Leid und dann mit einem
Dollar Zinsen zurückzahlen will woher
kommt der zweite Dollar man muss ihn
natürlich leihen es ist ein Ponzi System
da man die Schulden nie abbezahlen kann
und immer mehr anhäufen
muss seit 1971 haben die USA ein
Handelsdefizit im Verhältnis zur übrigen
Welt wir kaufen also viel mehr Produkte
von ihnen als sie insgesamt von uns
kaufen Japan und Korea verkaufen uns
elekroartikel der Nahe Osten verkauft
uns Öl China verkauft uns gefühlt das
ganze
supermarktangebot die USA zahlen dafür
in US-Dollar und alle sind zufrieden
aber würden die Länder diese
dollargewinne in ihre eigenen Währungen
konvertieren würden diese an Wert
gewinnen und das Land würde als
Handelspartner weniger
attraktiv stattdessen investieren diese
Länder ih dollne
Staatsanleihen die Länder der Welt
verkaufen ihre Waren an die USA im
Austausch für US-Dollar die von der US
Notenbank gegen Schuldscheine geliehen
wurden dann leihen die Länder den USA
ihre dollargewinne zurück indem sie
ihrerseits Schuldscheine
erwerben das Geld dieser Darlehen wird
zur Begleichung von Rechnungen und zur
Auszahlung früherer Kredite
verwendet dafür müssen aber immer
größere Kredite aufgenommen werden um
die gelenen Beträge mit Zinsen
zurückzuzahlen da alte Darlehen durch
neue größere Darlehen zurückgezahlt
werden wirkt es als würde die ganze Welt
ihr Geld in ein ponzisystem epischen
Ausmaßes
investieren wenn bei diesem Geschäft der
geldherstellung für Regierungen hier und
überall auf der Welt nicht mehr und mehr
Geld generiert würde bräche das ganze in
sich zusammen
denn es sind schließlich die neuen
Schulden mit denen die alten Schulden
beglichen
werden es ist ein ganz klassisches
ponzisystem damit die US-Wirtschaft
funktioniert müssen wir uns mehr und
mehr Geld von anderen Ländern leihen je
mehr Sie uns heute leihen desto mehr
müssen Sie uns in Zukunft leihen hören
sie irgendwann auf damit bricht alles
zusammen und wir können sie nicht
zurückbezahlen
jeden Freitagabend vergleicht Julia die
Preise der lokalen Supermärkte für Ihren
samstagmgen
Einkauf es gibt F Märkte in den Blocks
im unser Haus und Julia kauft alles dort
wo die Preise am niedrigsten und die
Qualität am höchsten
ist ein Schokoriegel kostete mal einen
vierel eine Tankfüllung 5 eineöpfige
Familie für pro
Woche
ohne greifbare Grundlage für Währungen
konnten Regierungen so viel Geld drucken
wie sie
wollten das hat den Wert unserer Währung
nach und nach
untergraben die Erschaffung all dieses
Geldes verringert den Wert der
bestehenden Dollar immer mehr wodurch
die Kaufkraft immer weiter
sinkt eine Galone Benzin kostete mal 31
Cent jetzt sind es etwa
der Normalverbraucher erlebt Inflation
als verringerte Kaufkraft dadurch sinkt
sein Lebensstandard wenn er nicht mit
der Inflationsrate Schritt halten
kann in vielen Bereichen ist der
Lebensstandard in Amerika heute
schlechter nehmen wir meine Großeltern
als Beispiel meine Großmutter musste nie
arbeiten obwohl mein Großvater nur
Schreiner war und sie acht Kinder hatten
könnte ein Schreiner ein Arbeiter im
Handwerk ohne high absl heute eine Frau
und acht Kinder finanzieren keine
Chance da die Inflation schneller stieg
als das Einkommen musste der
Lebensstandard mit immer drastischeren
Maßnahmen erhalten
werden jeden Tag beginnt die Arbeit der
Familie von
neuem bevor wir den Dollar vom Gold
trentnten ging üblicherweise der Mann
arbeiten und die Frau kümmerte sich um
Haus und
Familie in den 70ern arbeitete die Frau
dann aufgrund der Inflation auch man
brauchte also zwei Einkommen um die
gleichen Waren und Dienstleistungen zu
bezahlen in den 90ern hörten wir
aufzusparen die Sparquote fiel nahezu
auf null man musste das Geld ausgeben um
die gleichen waren und Dienste zu kaufen
und konnte nicht sparen dann in den
2000 die Frau arbeitete schon spisse
waren auf Null also liemang Geld wir
brauchten also erst zwei Einkommen
mussten aufhören zu sparen und zuletzt
Geld leih um mit der Inflation Schritt
zu
halten der Durchschnittsverbraucher
sieht sich nun gezwungen Geld zu leihen
und verschuldet sich dadurch
erheblich zuerst diente dies der
Aufrechterhaltung eines gehobenen
Lebensstandards doch mittlerweile ist es
allein für das Überleben
erforderlich es schint Regierungen indem
sie mehr und mehr Geld drucken und ihre
Währung entwerten ihrem Volk eine
verdeckte Zusatzsteuer
auferlegen Zentralbanken behaupten 2
oder 3% Inflation wären etwas Gutes
erstrebenswert sogar es sind aber
Steuern wieso sind 2 oder 3% Inflation
besser für das Land als keine
Inflation es heißt dann immer das sei
besser als Deflation und das Gefühl
gefällt ihr Einkommen würde um ein paar
Prozent steigen das wäre doch etwas
Gutes tatsächlich wird Ihnen jedoch Geld
gestohlen und ihr effektives Einkommen
sinkt wir erleben derzeit Inflation
angeblich steigt der VPI um 2 oder 3%
aber es fällt doch jedem auf dass die
Inflation viel größer ist womöglich
sogar
zweistellig die Kaufkraft des durch um
drtisch um dies zu verbergen verzerren
Regierungen jedoch die Daten ihrer
Berichte damit die Inflation viel
kleiner wirkt als sie tatsächlich
ist es gibt diese befremdliche
Unterscheidung zwischen Kerninflation
und Gesamtinflation die viele nicht
verstehen die Kerninflation ist dieser
Zielwert von 2% nicht weiter wichtig die
Gesamtinflation berüichtig auch Dinge
wie Energiepreise plötzliche
Steuererhöhungen und
dergleichen die Inflationsrate ist
verzerrt man nutzt allerlei Ausflüchte
um sie geringer erscheinen zu lassen als
sie ist würde die Regierung den VPI
genauso berechnen wie damals unter
Präsident Carter in den späten 70ern
wäre die Inflationsrate in den USA heute
9 oder
10% so sehr wird die Währung
entwertet der Grund dafür sind die
vielen inflations Verpflichtungen der
usregierung so sind z.B Hilfszahlungen
im Sozialsystem inflationsbereinigt und
an diese angepasst wenn Sie die
Inflationsrate in den offiziellen
Statistiken klein halten müssen sie
weniger zahlen und das Staatsdefizit
sinkt die blühende Metropole Toledo ist
eines der größten Zentren für die
Glasverarbeitung in Ohios fgrößter
Stadten geht es hingegen prär um Gummi
Rren ist die
gummiherstellungshauptstadt des Landes
sogar der Welt acren steht für Gummi in
einer Welt in der Währungen nur in
Relation zueinander bewertet werden
können Staaten den Wert ihrer Währung
künstlich verringern und ihrer Industrie
so einen Wettbewerbsvorteil verschaffen
ein Land mit einer schwachen Währung
kann Produkte billiger herstellen und so
für die internationale Verlagerung
ganzer Industriezweige sorgen dies ließ
sich zahose Male Städten auf der ganzen
Welt beobachten einige davon haben sich
immer noch nicht vom Verlust ihrer
Industrie
erholt die Menschen sind verzweifelt sie
haben studiert haben keine Arbeit finden
keine Arbeit müssen Studentenkredite
bezahlen haben erhöhte
Lebenshaltungskosten die FET sagt es
gebe keine Inflation aber man sieht doch
wie die Preise für Eier Milch und
Fleisch im Laden steigen die Spritpreise
an der Tankstelle steigen auch versteht
nicht wie sehr der einzelne betroffen
ist darum sind sie frustriert denn es
wird einem nirgendwo beigebracht das
Geld zu drucken ohne dass es gedeckt ist
die virung entwertet und all diese
Nebenwirkungen hervorruft die wir
beobachten steigende inflationskosten
Korruption
Günstlingswirtschaft all das hat in den
letzten Jahren Schlagzeilen
gemachtestbewegen interes phomen viele
Menschen sind fürchterlich wütend auf
die Wall Street auf das was mit ihrer
Kaufkraft geschieht sie sind wüend
darüber dass sie in den Nachrichten
erfahren die Manager dieser Banken
bekämen Boni in Millionenhöhe wähend sie
gleichzeitig dem Steuerzahler im Rahmen
der Bankenrettung auf der Tasche
liegen ja das macht sie
wütend leider demonstrieren die Menschen
zwar gegen die Wirtschaftskrise fordern
aber gleichzeitig mehr Sozialhilfe
staatliche krankenich
mehr statliche Kontrolle und Regulierung
dass mehr Geld erschaffen und in die
Gesellschaft gesteckt werden
soll und bemerken dabei jedoch nicht
dass diese Dinge die wahre Ursache sind
warum sie wütend auf die Straße
gehen während der einzelne nur mit Mühe
über die Runden kommt erzählt man uns es
sei eine normale
rez F sich diese Krise dann anders an
als vorangegangene
Rezessionen das ist alles andere als
normal es ist viel eher das Ende wir
erleben den Todeskampf unseres
40-jährigen Experiments mit
fiatwährungen welches in einem absoluten
Fehlschlag endet in Amerika ebenso wie
überall auf der
Welt bis 2008 liehen wir uns mehr und
mehr Geld um unseren Lebensstandard zu
erhalten
haben wir nun das Maximum erreicht und
können keine weiteren Schulden
aufnehmen heute findet in allen
Gesellschaftsschichten ein Schuldenabbau
statt die Verbraucher sind am Limit
jedes Mal wenn wir den Zyklus von
Höhenflug und Pleite durchlaufen haben
wurde mit der Pleite die nächste
Inflation losgetreten um die Wirtschaft
anzukurbeln wodurch jedes Mal mehr und
mehr Schulden angehäuft
worden jetzt ist der Punkt erreicht an
dem wir keine Schulden mehr machen
können Banken Gewehren Kredite nicht
mehr so leichtfertig wie zuvor viele
Bürger sind damit beschäftigt alte
Schulden abzubezahlen anstatt neue
Schulden aufzunehmen das ist zum einen
vorsichtig und vernünftig zum anderen
eine Bedrohung für die
Weltwirtschaft als gewaltiges ponziystem
ist die Weltwirtschaft für ihren
Fortbestand darauf angewiesen dass immer
mehr und immer größere Schulden
angehäuft W
wenn wir nicht über unsere Verhältnisse
leben und versuchen mit dem Geld das wir
haben
auszukommen bricht die
währungsversorgung durch die Zinsen in
sich
zusammen darum müssen wir weiterhin
jeden Monat mehr Dollar erschaffen und
uns leihen als wir an Schulden abbauen
können so wie das System aktuell
aufgestellt ist muss die Geldversorgung
konstant ausgeweitet werden damit nicht
untergeht Politiker und Kommentatoren
predigen ein gemäßigtes Leben und die
Begleichung der Schulden dadurch würde
aber die Wirtschaft zusammenbrechen sie
würde regelrecht
verschwinden alle Politiker sind in der
Zwickmühle wenn sie nicht zur Rettung
eilen bricht über Nacht alles zusammen
und das will niemand solange er an der
Macht ist darum wollen alle die
Verantwortung weitergeben und lassen den
Kelch quasi an sich vorüberziehen
es ist aber das Ende der Fahnenstange
erreicht wir können den Kelch an
niemanden mehr weitergeben und müssen
selbst damit fertig werden was mit jedem
Mal als er weitergegeben wurde
schwieriger
wurde es ist ein großes erdrückendes
Problem
geworden die Finanzkrise von 2008 mag
das erste Vorzeichen vom Ende des
ponystems gewesen sein doch Regierungen
auf der ganzen Welt machten keine
Anstalten es einfach zu lassen also
verzögerten sie das Unvermeidliche durch
die Rettung maruder
Finanzinstitutionen sie kauften faule
Hypotheken und nahmen im Namen des
Volkes Schulden
auf 2009 und 2010 wurde die Krise
einfach überbrückt indem man Banken
rettete und stetig neues Geld druckte
und in systempunkte man sollte nicht
vergessen dass Regierungen auf kurze
sichtgebnisse
K langfristig wurden die Probleme aber
nicht gelöst die Schulden sind noch da
die Banken sind noch immer insolvent und
bessern sich nicht die Wirtschaft
stagniert nichts wurde
gelöst indem sie sich immer wieder
freikaufen Geld drucken das System damit
überfluten und die Kaufkraft verwessern
lösen Sie das Problem nicht sie schieben
es nur ein wenig auf und machen es noch
schlimmer machen wir nun also einfach so
weiter und trocken mehr Geld die Bilanz
der F von 800 Milliarden auf 3 Billionen
sollen es jetzt 6 Billionen werden kommt
nach dem 800 Milliarden Konjunkturpaket
eins mit 2 Billionen das könnte man
schon machen aber so würde die Währung
mangelsvertrauen womöglich
Einbrechen der offene geldhann der
usnenbank stützt die Wirtschaft
kurzfristig durchaus doch was sind die
Folgen wenn man in diesem mastab einfach
Geld
truckt
ich erwarte dass der Wert des Dollars
sehr schnell einbrechen wird innerhalb
weniger Tage ob nun um 20 30 oder
40% viele flüchten sich zur Sicherheit
in den Dollar was wenn Sie nun merken
dass es hier gar keine Sicherheit gibt
und dass sie aus dem Dollar fliehen
müssen der aktuell von der Angst
profitiert was wenn die Menschen um den
Dollar
fürchten zusätzlich zur gewaltigen
Inflation besteht auch das Risiko dass
die US Notenbank indem sie weiterhin
leichtfertig Geld druckt das globale
Vertrauen in den USDollar erschüttern
könnte eine Währungskrise halte ich für
sehr wahrscheinlich was genau sie wann
verursachen wird ist schwer vorherz
sagen vielleicht kommt sie überraschend
durch eine Naturkatastrophe einen
politischen Schock oder einfach durch
Vertrauensverlust da würde schon eine
einfache Auktion des Finanzministeriums
reichen scheitert wodurch die Zinsen
steigen dann reagieren die großen
hgefonds und stoßen ihre Dollar ab
gefolgt von ausländischen Zentralbanken
die aus dem Dollar flüchten und schon
ist es
passiert wie bei jedem ponziystem
erkennen die Teilnehmer irgendwann wie
der Hase läuft und wollen aussteigen
wodurch alles in sich
zusammenfällt wenn private und
freiwillige Teilnehmer also private
Investoren und auslische
nicht mehr weiterkaufen kann die
Notenbank einschreiten und die
Forderungen derer die aus dem ponziystem
Aussteigen wollen
erfüllen wenn die US Notenbank dann aber
der einzige verbleibende Käufer ist ist
das Ende der Fahnenstange erreicht und
die Hyperinflation
beginnt Hyperinflation ist ein derart
schneller Anstieg der Inflationsrate
dass die Menschen das Vertrauen in die
Währung verlieren was dann auch zur
führt galoppierende Inflation im
besiegten
Deutschland die Mark ist so wertlos
geworden dass man sie als Tapete oder
zum Anheizen des Ofens
verwendet die Regierung sieht sich also
gezwungen so viel Geld auszugeben und zu
leihen dass der Markt irgendwann nicht
mehr gewillt ist entsprechende Mengel zu
verleihen dann schreitet die Zentralbank
ein und verwandelt die Schulden in neue
Währung die große Frage ist wobei ich
die Antwort selbst nicht kenne bei wie
viel Inflation 5 10 15 20% beginnt die
Panik wenn es soweit ist werden aber
sicherlich alle in Panik
verfallen infolge einer Hyperinflation
steigen die Preise für Waren und
Dienstleistungen rapide wodurch die
Menschen sich ihrer Währung noch
schneller
entledigen dann fangen die Leute an
Waren zu kaufen nur um ihr Papiergeld
loszuwerden das treib fage nach
Papiergeld paradoxerweise noch weiter an
weil man ja damit einkaufen
will somit sinkt der Wert des
Papiergelds noch bevor es in Umlauf
kommt im Alltag wird man nach Kräften
greifbare Dinge bekommen
wollen statt einer Dose Thunfisch kauft
man dann zwei man weiß ja dass die
gleiche Dose morgen oder vielleicht
sogar schon später am gleichen Tag mehr
kosten
wird Manes was irgendwie greifbar
ist das wird mit einem großen
wirtschaftlichen Leid
einhergehen viele Ruheständler in
Amerika werden sich Arbeit suchen müssen
weil ihre Altersvorsorge sich plötzlich
in Luft aufgelöst
hat sie haben sich auf ein nationales
ponziystem in bester Bernie madow Manier
verlassen auch Immobilien werden
verfallen da die Menschen zuerst ihre
unmittelbaren Bedürfnisse decken müssen
und kein Geld für Reparaturen und
Instandhaltung
wenn Vermieter keine Miete mehr bezahlt
bekommen wie sollen sie die Immobilien
erhalten und Steuern
zahlen die ganze Wirtschaft wird von der
Last der Inflation erdrückt
werden die erste Reaktion der Notenbank
wird natürlich sein noch mehr Inflation
zu verursachen indem sie die Wirtschaft
mit noch mehr neuem Geld anzukurbeln
versuchen was ja eigentlich die Wurzel
des Problems
ist auf den
erstenck ur die US zu
betreffen da aber so viele Länder ihre
Rücklagen in Form von US-Anleihen Lagern
könnte ein Vertrauensverlust des Dollars
eine globale Krise auslösen die
sämtliche Länder der Erde betreffen
würde eine Hyperinflation des Dollars
hätte weitreichende Folgen die
Auswirkungen einer Hyperinflation lassen
sich in Ländern wie es sbabwe beobachten
was passiert aber wenn dieob wrung
Hyperinflation erfährt das hatten wir
noch nicht und die Folgen sind unmöglich
vorherzusagen die logische Folge einer
Hyperinflation des Dollars wären massive
wirtschaftliche Probleme für alle
anderen Währungen der Welt da die
Reserven all dieser Währungen letztlich
in Dollar
[Musik]
liegen
seit dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges
sind dutzende Währungen untergegangen
und die Ursache war immer die gleiche
schlechte politische Entscheidungen
aktuell treffen die USA schlechte
politische Entscheidungen und die
Zentralbank verwaltet die Währung auch
nicht gut der Untergang des Dollars ist
somit unausweichlich wir sind auf dem
Weg zum Friedhof der
fiatwährungen
der Markt die Privatwirtschaft die
Menschen werden plötzlich verstehen was
los ist dann beginnt der Herdentrieb das
kann über Nacht
passieren wann es passiert ist für uns
nahezu unmöglich
vorherzusagen aber es besteht immer das
Risiko dass wir eines morgens aufwachen
und uns in einer gänzlich anderen Welt
wiederfinden vielleicht nicht über eine
Nacht sondern eine Woche oder einen
Monat aber wenn es seit ist wird schnell
oh es vorhehen
Ken Hyperinflation ist nur eines der
Szenarien die die Welt heute bedrohen
die Geschichte lehrt uns jedoch dass
jede Nation die ihre Wirtschaft auf ein
künstliches fiatsystem stützt das
gleiche Schicksal
ereilt
Unheil die Quote der Fehlschläge liegt
Nachweis bei 100% firungen schitern
immer Jahren begann dann das große
Experiment bei dem alle Währungen mit
dem Ende des Breton wood Systems
gleichzeitig zu fiatwährungen
wurden die Welt muss einen Ausweg aus
diesem Dollar basierten Währungssystem
finden eine Währung braucht eine Basis
man kann sie nicht auf nichts
Stützen ich vergleiche es immer mit dem
alten ersten Superman Film in dem Lis
Lane vom Hochhaus stürzt und Superman
sie fängt und sagt ich habe dich keine
Sorge und
und wer hat dich so geht es den Dollar
wer stützt ihn sicher nicht Superman und
selbst kann der Dollar nicht fliegen es
war einmal Gold das den Dollar stützte
aber jetzt hat jeder sein Schiff an die
Titanic der Währungen gebunden und alle
werden gemeinsam
untergehen wenn das Vertrauen in den
US-Dollar schwindet was wahrscheinlich
noch vor 2020 passieren wird wäre das
nicht das erste Mal in der
Geschichte zurückkehren das Vertrauen
schafft und Gold schafft
Vertrauen die einzige Lösung ist die
Rückkehr zu einer echten gesunden
Währung echtes Geld mit echtem
Gegenwert es muss nicht Gold oder Silber
sein aber in der Vergangenheit kamen
Gesellschaften durch Versuch und Irrtum
allen Experimenten zumtrotz immer wieder
zu Gold und Silber zurück es scheint
also nicht die schlechteste Idee zu
sein Betracht all der Unsicherheiten der
heutigen Welt erscheint eine Rückkehr zu
einer Wirtschaft auf Basis von Gold nur
logisch warum also wird über eine
derartige Rückkehr noch nicht einmal
diskutiert die Antwort ist so einfach
wie alarmierend diejenigen die an der
Spitze sitzen und vom Ponzi System
profitieren wollen nicht dass es
endet viele glauben nun der Goldpreis
würde unterdrückt um es als globales
austauschmedium weniger attraktiv zu
machen Regierungen versuchen den
Goldpreis niedrig zu halten damit der
Dollar als angemessene Leitwährung für
die Welt wahrgenommen
wird der Dollar hat diesen Status aber
überhaupt nicht verdient da die USA ihn
so schlecht
verwalten Gruppen wie das Gold antitrust
Action Comm kurz Gata verfolgen die in
ihren Augen gezielte Unterdrückung des
Preises von Gold und Silber durch
zweifelhafte
[Musik]
Methoden wir haben 12 Jahre lang Beweise
für die Manipulation des Goldpreises
gesammelt bei einem Mordfall würde die
Jury ohne jeden Zweifel auf schuldig
pleren aber wir müssen alle Beweise und
ihre Zusammenhänge immer wieder
erklären der Goldpreis wird auf viele
Arten manipuliert nicht alle sind
einfach nachzuweisen viele wie Verkäufe
durch Zentralbanken sind jedoch klar
verzeichnet zwischen
und 2002 verkaufte die britische
Zentralbank türichterweise einen
gewaltigen Teil der britischen
Goldreserven für durchschnittlich
275 $ pro Unze der Erlös wurde in Euro
und Dollar investiert auch die
Regierungen von Kanada Frankreich der
Schweiz und anderen Staaten verkauften
zu der Zeit ihr
Gold wir wissen dass die Zentralbanken
400 Tonnen Gold pro Jahr
verkauften warum es war die mit Abstand
dümmste Entscheidung des Jahrzehnts und
sie taten es wieder und wieder heute
kostet Gold 300 bis 1600 fast
1700 warum habt ihr es also verkauft um
den Preis zu drücken es war koordiniert
damit alle weiterhin den Währungen
Vertrauen Greens Gand vor dem Kongress
dass sie den Goldpreis manipulierten als
er sagte die Zentralbanken wären bereit
Gold in wachsenden Mengen zu leihen
sollte der Preis steigen sie taten es
also
schon sollte der Goldpreis steigen
bedeutet die Unterdrückung war das Ziel
die Taten es also schon und er gestand
es dem Kongress
gegenüber Zentralbanken können die
Goldreserven ihrer Nationen natürlich
legal veräußern doch nutzten sie zur
Unterdrückung des Goldpreises auch
dubiosere
Praktiken einige Ermittler behaupten
westliche Zentralbanken hätten ihre
Goldreserven an goldbanken
verliehen goldbanken verkaufen Gold mit
dem Ziel es später zu einem günstigeren
Preis
zurückzukaufen der Erlös dieser Verkäufe
floss in der Vergangenheit auch in US
Bundesanleihen das ist an sich zwar kein
Problem doch verzeichnen die
Zentralbanken ihr eigenes Gold und das
Gold das sie den goldbanken geliehen
haben als einen Posten so kann eine
Zentralbank zwar behaupten sie hätte
Goldreserven in einer gewissen Höhe doch
ein Großteil davon kann an goldbanken
verliehen sein die dieses Gold womöglich
gegen Bundesanleihen verkauft
haben eine Möglichkeit der Intervention
auf dem Goldmarkt ist das Verleihen von
Gold an sogenannte goldbanken die das
Gold dann auf dem Markt
verkaufen das unterdrückt den Preis
ebenso wie direkte verkäfe der
Zentralbanken taucht aber nicht in ihren
Büchern
auf vor ein paar Jahren änderte die
usstaatskasse wie Gold verzeichnet wird
sodass nun einige Forderungen ebenso wie
der Goldbestand gemeinsam aufgeführt
werden sie verbuchen also das was sie
tatsächlich haben und das was ihnen
geschuldet wird als ein und dasselbe was
betrügerischer Buchführung gleich
kommt doch wozu der Aufwand
und silbereises warum bedohen Gold und
Silberpreise das
ponzystem Gold und nationale Währungen
stehen in Konkurrenz zueinander denn
Gold ist der einzige Konkurrent
nationaler Währungen Gold ist Geld und
die Währungen sind Geldersatz der statt
Gold
zirkuliert beiungen hat die Regierung
die Macht bei E Geld
dieölkerung die Regierung denn sie kann
nur ihre Steuereinnahmen ausgeben die
Bevölkerung streäubt sich gegen steuern
aber wenn die Regierung einfach Geld
leihen und drucken kann fällt der
Widerstand Weg die Regierung kann
einfacher wachsen wenn sie einem etwas
im Austausch für nichts verspricht und
genau das tun sie Gold schützt die
Menschen vor unverantwortlichen
Regierungen Gold beschränkt Regierungen
denn die würden gerne tun was sie wollen
doch gold steht ihnen im Weg Gold ist
der Feind übergriffiger Regierungen aber
ein Freund der Freiheit ein Schutz des
Einzelnen vor der
Regierung Gold konkurriert mit dem
Dollar ein hoher Preis bedroht die
Inflation es ist ein Barometer für die
US-Wirtschaft aktuell auf Höhenflug
während die Welt zusammenbricht es zeigt
uns wie schlimm die Lage ist also wollen
die Wall Street und die Regierung mit
ihren Politikern den Preis
unterdrücken die Wall Street will nicht
dass du zum Münzkontor gehst und Gold
und Silbermünzen kaufst sie wollen dir
Papiere andrehen die Regierung genauso
zusammen mit der Wall
Street Gold im Besitz des Volkes ist die
Kontrolle der Regierung die Regierung
kann kein Geld erschaffen wenn es Gold
ist sie erschaffen nur Papiergeld aus
dem Nichts mit diesem Papiergeld können
Sie dann Kriege führen oder es als
politisches Mittel zum Zweck nutzen um
ihre Freunde zu
bereichern also kämpfen Regierungen
schon das ganze Jahrhundert lang gegen
Gold an
trotz all dieser Bemühungen den Preis
von Gold und Silber niedrig zu halten
stieg die Nachfrage nach Gold und Silber
aufgrund der Instabilität des Marktes
zuletzt drastisch was ein
tiefergreifendes Problem der
Zentralbanken
offenbarte westliche Zentralbanken haben
nun das Problem dass sie viel Gold
verkauft haben um den Goldpreis zu
unterdrücken sie werden jetzt
vonankeneral dieses ursprünglichen
Kartells vorgeführt die mit großem
alifer Gold
aufkaufen China Russland Indien sogar
Mexiko diese ganzen kleineren
Zentralbanken abseits des Mainstreams
die nicht Teil der Elite des
internationalen Bankenwesens sind
sichern sich jetzt hunderte Tonnen
davon um den Goldpreis zu unterdrücken
mussten westlicheentr die nationalen
Goldreserven verkaufen oder verleihen da
das Gold dabei jedoch ihre Tresore nur
selten verlässt weiß niemand ob sie
nicht mehr Gold verkaufen oder verleihen
als sie tatsächlich
haben sollte dem so sein wäre es eine
der größten Betrugsmaschen der
Weltgeschichte ein gewaltiger Schwindel
doch nicht von einzelnen ausgehend
sondern von ganzen
Regierungen dasist Gold der zentral
liegt in der Federal Reserve in New York
und der Bank of England bleibt also in
ihren Kellern bei internationalen
Verkäufen verschieben Sie nur ein paar
Barren von einem Haufen auf den nächsten
machen ein anderes Etikett daran oder
verändern nur einen
Registereintrag da sind allerdings recht
kreative Registereinträge dabei und ich
glaube nicht dass tatsächlich alles von
dem Gold vorhanden
ist das Problem bleibt bestehen wenn
alle besonders die großen Fische ihr
Gold gleichzeitig geliefert haben
wollten wäre das einfach nicht
möglich beim meisten Geld ist es so dass
jede Unze mehrfach verkauft wurde und
mehrere Personen meinen es würde ihnen
gehören ich sage es immer wieder wenn
man es nicht in die Hand nehmen kann
gehört es einem
nicht das Spiel muss früher oder später
enden irgendwann wird das physische Gold
und Silber eingefordert wir sehen das
auch heute schon
der Mangel an Verantwortlichkeit bei
goldverkäufen westlicher Zentralbanken
hat bisher kaum Besorgnis erregt wenn
jedoch mehr und mehr Goldkäufer
physische Lieferungen verlangen werden
die Zentralbanken die zu viel verkauft
oder ihre nationalen Goldreserven
verliehen haben einen gewaltigen Skandal
auslösen infolge derartiger Betrügereien
könnten Goldkäufer ob Einzelpersonen
pensions oder hgefonds oder sogar ganze
Nationen
betrogen
werden es erinnert ein wenig an den MD
Skandal bei Fox in London und den MAD
Skandal die Presse ist mit den
Superreichen und der Politik ins Bett
gegangen leider ändert sich immer erst
etwas wenn die Bombe geplatzt
ist mad ging hoch MD ging hoch Gold wird
ebenso hoch gehen mehr noch als diese
beiden da es weltweit das Finanzwesen
betrifft
[Musik]
die Politiker und Bänker von heute haben
alles verlernt außer mehr Geld zu
drucken und die Währung
aufzublasen das ist ihr ganzes Repertoir
wenn wir uns weiterhin auf sie und ihre
Führung bei der Lösung von Problemen
verlassen wie könnten wir etwas anderes
erwarten Sie können nichts
anderes die einzige andere Möglichkeit
wäre die Inflation zu beenden und zu
einer gesunden Währung zurückzukehren
aber das wollen sie nicht denn dann
wären sie ja
arbeitslos das ponzystem wäre am
Ende obwohl sich Risse im Finanzsystem
auftun sind die einzigen
Lösungsvorschläge der Regierungen
diejenigen die uns der Katastrophe immer
näher
bringen zwar kann der Einzelne die Welt
nicht selbst retten doch kann man
Schritte ergreifen um zumindest sich und
seine Familie zu
schützen man kann nicht von einem Ponzi
betetrüger verlangen dass er ein
ehrliches Geschäft
führt das kann er
nicht man kann also nicht von den ganzen
Ponzi Betrügern der Regierung verlangen
dass sie die Krise auf andere Art und
Weise lösen sollen sie wissen ja nicht
wie das
geht wir müssen aufhören uns für die
Lösung unserer Probleme auf die gleichen
Menschen mit der gleichen
zu
verlassen wenn die Regierungen nicht zum
Goldstandard zurückkehren wollen müssen
die Bürger das selbst tun regierungen
können so viel fiatgeld erschaffen wie
Sie wollen dafür ist es da warum sollte
man dem also Vertrauen den Politikern
den Bürokraten und Zentralbankern wenn
man etwas Echtes haben kann etwas mit
intrinsischem wert das weiterhin selten
bleiben
wird was hätte man lieber Gold oder f
wir beobachten überall auf der Welt wie
die Menschen erkennen dass Gold seinen
Wert mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit viel
besser bewaht als ein Stück
Papier es geht nicht darum dass der
Goldpreis steigt sondern dass der Wert
des Dollars sinkt die menschliche
Anstrengung und Kaufkraft bei Gold
bleibt gleich mit einer Unze kann man
heute noch genauso viel kaufen wie vor
2000 Jahren die Gewinnung einer un Gold
verschlingt heute noch genauso viel
menschliche Anstrengung wie vor 2000
Jahren durch diese aufwandsgleichheit
bei der Gewinnung ist Gold zu
stabil Gold ist finanzielle
Absicherung beim Goldbesitz geht es
darum dass man sich schützen
will man muss es haben schon alleine um
ruhig schlafen zu
können sonst bleibt einem nichts bei
Katastrophen wie wir sie schon oft
erlebt haben wie schützt man sich
sonst das aktuelle Finanzsystem mag
untergehen doch jedes Chaos bietet auch
Chancen der Zusammenbruch des alten
Systems könnte die Tür zu großem
Wohlstand
aufstoßen es ist sicher nicht das Ende
der Welt vielleicht noch nicht mal von
Amerika für viele Länder wird es Beginn
eines Aufschwungs markieren da eine von
ihnen genommen wird die Welt wird nicht
länger Billionen an Amerika leihen
müssen damit wir hier verbrauchen können
ohne zu
produzieren dieser Untergang wird der
Welt gut tun wir sollten ih als
Weltgemeinschaft nicht fürchten sondern
begrüßen es wird die größte
wohlstandsverlagerung der Geschichte
sein die globale Währungskrise wird eine
größere Verlagerung von Wohlstand
verursachen als wir sie je Geschichte
beobachten konnten und zwar plötzlich
also ist es auch die größte
Chance Millionen von Menschen stellen
sich heute die
Frage was ist Geld was sollte es sein
und sie machen große fortchritte dabei
besonders die junge
[Musik]
Generation auch morgen geht die Sonne
auf wie schon millionenfach zuvor
Pendler auf und fahren ins Büro um ihr
Tagewerk zu
verrichten Landwirte kümmern sich um die
Ernte und Bauarbeiter errichten neue
Infrastruktur doch wird die Welt noch
dieselbe sein 2008 er alte die Welt ein
wegruf der größte Finanzcrash der
Weltgeschichte wurde durch die gleichen
schlechten Entscheidungen verzögert die
ihn verursacht hatten die gewaltige
Bankenrettung erkaufte uns keine Lösung
nur zeitit in der die Verantwortlichen
einem sterbenden System die letzten
Dollar
abrangen aber gleichzeitig erhielten
diejenigen die den Abgrund kommen sahen
die Gelegenheit sich selbst und ihre
Familien vor dem bevorstehenden Fall zu
schützen diese Zeit könnte sich als das
wertvollste aller Güter
erweisen es gibt in der Geschichte immer
wieder diese kurzen Momente in denen die
absicherungswährung der vergangenen 5000
Jahre zeitgleich die Wertanlage mit der
größten potenziellen Wachstumschance in
Sachen Kaufkraft
ist so etwas erleben wir gerade Geld ist
die beste
Wertanlage man stöst Währung ab kauft
Geld und kann sich später wahrscheinlich
sehr viel mehr davon
kaufen am besten wäre es jedoch wenn die
Menschen Verantwortung übernehmen und in
Sachen Finanzen informieren
wird das Wichtigste ist sich nicht mehr
bei allen Entscheidungen von den Banken
Brokern und anderen Leuten leiten zu
lassen und sich für sich selbst stark zu
[Musik]
machen